well as many of you probably already
know a huge controversy erupted this
week involving Pope Benedict the Pope
made some statements in his speech that
have enraged Muslims all over the world
he apologized for his remarks but many
Muslims are still furious at him folks
I'd like to apologize tonight not about
Pope Benedict this has nothing to do
with that or with me being Catholic I
want to apologize about one of our shows
Pope characters.the always disappointing
FedEx Pope there he is right there he's
easily one of the worst characters ever
let's bring him in right now FedEx Pope
want to get in here
now
let's lazy gentlemen ladies and
gentlemen space that this is this is one
crappy character it's just a guy with a
white bathrobe and a FedEx box on his
head to be honest we thought about it
the only character that even comes close
to being this lame is Manzi the half man
half pansy very okay yeah compared to
the FedEx Pope even Manzi looks pretty
good so to Muslims Christians Jews
Buddhists and everyone else on earth
please forgive us for creating this
pathetic and forgettable and pointless
character FedEx Pope could you get lost
please I'm sorry I'm sorry there we go
is the long walk of shame for the FedEx
Pope the traditional lowering of the
head I mean traditional falling off of
the crappy FedEx box
Manzi you can stay you're all right with
me Manzi the half
that guy went to college alright we'll
take a break let me come back Jim
Cramer's here and stick around